[Music]
[Applause]
there were only three reporters allowed
to go to the kansas city chiefs practice
yesterday and one of those joins us now
nate taylor the
chiefs beat writer for the athletic nate
thanks for joining us
uh what can you supply as far as an
update on
let's start with patrick mahomes on what
you saw
and what you expect the next couple of
days
yeah thank you dan for having me on um
it was
a pretty normal day considering that
patrick reynolds is in the concussion
protocol but there's real strong
optimism within the organization
that mahomes will be cleared either
today or tomorrow out of the concussion
protocol which will allow him to start
in sunday's game against the buffalo
bills i watched patrick mahomes
for the early portion of practice still
through the ball with a lot of pace a
lot of accuracy he was working on his
footwork i know fans have
some questions about the left big toe
injury that he had against the cleveland
browns
but he looked to move pretty well from
my vantage point it'll just be a matter
of how much can he
increase his speed and his obviously
acceleration
if he needs to scramble out of the
pocket if he does play on sunday but all
signs are pointing to
him getting the chance to lead the
chiefs to another super bowl at
arrowhead stadium
i just don't know if mahomes from what
i'm told didn't have a concussion but
once you're placed
into concussion protocol nate you still
have to go through it
correct and the easiest way to explain
this to
fans is you know he did not answer
all the questions when he was in the
blue tent or when he was in the locker
room correctly which allowed
you know a neurologist to basically say
that you know he's having issues
so let's put him in the protocol even if
we don't fully diagnose him with the
concussion now andy reid
on a couple of occasions dan has not
said full on that
patrick mahomes had a concussion maybe
we'll learn that sort of after the fact
or after the season's over
but once you're in the protocol you have
to go through every step that means
obviously balance testing
he has to be seen by both the chief's
medical staff and an independent
neurologist both of those parties
have to clear him and he's gone through
a rigorous amount of test work because
after every practice
every workout you're sort of given
instructions on how you work mentally
from your baseline back in the preseason
again all these things look to be taking
care of themselves
in an orderly fashion and for the chiefs
patrick mahomes should be on the field
if he doesn't have any concussion-like
symptoms that sort of come back to him
as a setback
what about clyde edwards hilaire's
availability
i think he's going to play dan i think
he's practiced the last two days
he is expected to practice today at
practice um
look he would have been a 50 50 sort of
chance last week and i think andy reid
and the medical staff made the right
choices to tell the rookie
hey let's wait and see if we can get to
the ac championship game he had his best
game of the season against the buffalo
bills 161 rushing yards
i'm not sure if he's going to give that
level of production on sunday
but he is another weapon particularly as
a receiver too in that andy reid screen
game
so i think the chiefs will have both of
their star players in the back
field it's just a matter of how many
touches will clyde edwards alert get
and how effective can we see from him
early on in the game
what do i take away from the eric
biennames situation about
getting a head coaching position because
i thought he would have his
choice here nate now we're down to one
and
it's still open what do you
is your sense that the enemy gets this
job
i'm not sure um that's still kind of up
in the air i feel like
the houston texans have not really
floated anything much at all
about where they're looking in terms of
a head coaching vacancy
but overall in the big picture of the
league it's an embarrassment that eric
vietnamese is somehow
overqualified or not qualified enough or
does he call the plays but
you know he's under andy reid how much
you know true
you know credit goes to him for the
development of patrick mahomes
so in the chiefs organization what i've
heard a lot
was last year it was a lot of anger a
lot of frustration as to why eric the
enemy was not given one of these head
coaching jobs and sort of
they were able to sort of use that as
partly some motivation for him
when they went out and won the super
bowl where they felt like okay now he
can go into these interviews the next
year
and sort of say hey i've done everything
that could be asked of me as an
offensive coordinator i've helped
patrick mahomes i've won us a super bowl
guys like travis kelsey and tyree kill
credit him a ton
for their own development and their
professionalism since they came into the
league so
everybody knows he's a true leader this
year it's utter confusion and just
disappointment for the fact that
eric b enemy is a
candidate that should be taken with
serious consideration
it is kind of appalling that nfl owners
have not
seen the same things that you and i see
dan and you know a couple weeks ago andy
reid when he was
starting to get to that week 17 news
cycle of hey how's your guy going to do
this year what do you want from him
where do you think he could go
andre was pretty blunt in putting it on
the owners it's his
owner's issue it is an owner situation
and even clark hunt can't get some
owners
in the league his own peers to call him
to see
why eric enemy is the right choice to be
a head coach
i think about the example last year
where jerry jones and clark hunt did not
did not talk
and therefore airbnb was not given an
interview request from
the dallas cowboys now they went their
own direction with mike mccarthy
and we'll see where that goes but that
sort of explains the issue at home
not even a respected owner in the league
like clark hunt can sort of sway
or sort of give advice to other owners
in the league about why eric the enemy
should be a viable option to lead a
football team i'll leave you with this
though nate
andy reed 62. has has he talked about a
time frame of how long he coaches and
is there a chance that and i don't know
why andy would step down given what he
has but
with eric bienemy is there a chance that
hey you may not get this job
you're the coach in waiting here if
something were to happen and that would
take
quite a bit because i agree dan um then
airbnb i think would be the
coach in line to follow andy reid the
problem is
you know when patrick mahomes signed his
10-year extension he got pretty much
clearance from andy reid that i ain't
going anywhere man like i'm going to be
your coach
for the it's for the foreseeable future
right um andy reid basically told me
back in the summer
he may do he might do he might do this
until he's 70 which kind of takes you
through most of the contract extension
with patrick mahomes that will last in
2032. so
as long as andy reid has good health as
long as he's still
on the cutting edge of innovation in
terms of offensive play calling and play
design
and obviously he has the talent around
him from the front office i don't see
how andy reid leaves within the next
five years
and he can honestly push this to 70
because he sees the success that bill
belichick has had
and a lot of people need to realize that
both of these guys
are of a certain age and they're still
really really successful
given all the younger coaches coming
into the league trying to come after
them
nate good stuff thanks for visiting with
us and uh have fun this weekend
thank you sir it should be quite a blast
i hope it's a i hope it's a classic i
hope it's another afc championship
classic
he's nate taylor he covers the chiefs
for the athletic and was one of three
reporters only three reporters who were
able to
go to practice